real quick
um it's crazy because the
the most memorable verses that i can
think of this year when i say verses i
don't mean the battle but like people's
verses
um they they're they're free
like to me that the one now mind you i
really have to sit down and think about
this
but i think of conway
firing the booth that's you know what
you asked me about moment that's what i
wanted to say
conway's freestyle on charlie slaw
wow bruh i watch that once a week
i do too you know also i also watched
your joint with freddie gibbs when you
did last year
oh yeah you know what you know funny
story about that is fred came to the
studio and was like uh
like we're doing an interview and then i
was like oh you know you got a rap right
and he literally wrote that [ __ ] in like
five minutes
and then nailed it yeah like he was like
yo uh
pick a beat so we picked the drake money
in the grave and then he was like just
let me chill in here for five minutes
and just come up with something
and then he was like come back in and
then he laid it down
no [ __ ] yeah wow he didn't come to the
station that day with the
expectations to rap and then he laid
down some crazy [ __ ] that's
amazing fred's a [ __ ] mutant like
that's i thought that was like prepared
no nah bro yeah no fred's a [ __ ]
alien bro
and then obviously you know he did the
la leakers freestyle last year which was
[ __ ] crazy yes baby
yeah once a week be an actual
remix with him in a dom kennedy another
verse that like
it also is la leakers verse this year um
and that's the simba freestyle man yo
get out of my head kev
yo i was just about to say kev simba
is going to be a problem like if i had
to do an honorable mention
best right he's on that list he's
whoo simba is amazing
that freestyle yo was [ __ ]
crazy simba is nice so many and just the
confidence and the
and just the delivery of those lines and
that freestyle we're so
s like and mind you out he's a really
good friend of mine like
really good close like he was on our
show like three years ago like to give
you some insight
i've been known simba for a while and
man
his project is you know it's crazy
because his project didn't come out the
way it was supposed to come out
so like two weeks ago they were playing
me some like they a lot of the songs
were on there right but like
there's there's a song called westside
griselda that was supposed to be on the
album
with him and jason cash that because the
samples didn't work out but
but yes simba's crazy he's he's
incredible like i'm interested to see
what he's going to do in 2021
like he's the kind of rap i like rappers
like that it's like when you when i
listen to them it makes me want to quit
rapping
and i can't even rap right like what am
i doing this for
it's like [ __ ] let me start from scratch
like
he's he's a rapper's rap he's dope man
like i want to get
more in tune to what he's got going on
in 2021
yeah i think he's gonna have a crazy
year um and then and then i think the
congrats russ freestyle was probably
uh up there as well i think and it's
crazy because those are the three that
just come to my head and
and i'm not saying that there aren't
better verses but it's like all three of
those verses are all from freestyles
technically
absolutely the congratulation from russ
is really dope um i listen to that
probably like once a week as well
um love the absolute verse on you didn't
put absolutes verse on your on your
features i wanted to pick one from each
other that's fair i want to put multiple
but it could have
easily been absolutely i went with the
crooked eye because he set the tone
and yes crooked i just went ape [ __ ] on
that
that uh on stockholm syndrome um but
i like freddie gibbs man freddie gibbs
on 100 ounce 500 ounces
on west side guns album was that was the
one where he had the line about uh
about uh take a load off this low
management right yeah
yeah yeah that [ __ ] was crazy like marcy
and uh west side
i love that beat alchemist is a [ __ ]
fool
uh he killed that joint i love
conway conway whatever kind of conway
and freddie are like ken and ryu like
i'm on the edge of my seat anytime he's
right